romantic heidelberg high above the neck
our River the city's landmark castle is
in full view from the old bridge in the
advent period Heidelberg's old town
turned into a giant christmas market
boasting 140 stands the ice skating rink
at kyles cuts is a favorite with
children meanwhile the grown-ups Hydra
burgers and tourists alike get to warm
themselves with mulled wine a must for
every Christmas market yes so soon I
love the smell and the taste of it it
puts Christmas in your stomach imagine
we do enjoy miss this James and we will
try it again next time the spoonful but
it's the best thing about Christmas
mulled wine and seeing friends at the
Christmas market in the Christmas market
in Heidelberg old town Christoph
Schneider has been serving mulled wine
for the past 25 years whenever there's a
lull he lives the pot lid and let out
the fragrance team to draw more
customers
mmm so what does help most people come
after work after 5pm then it gets really
full people are having a good time few
spots on his arms cut off Schneider is
especially proud of his new creation a
multimer low it's less sweet than
conventional mold wines the good people
say they drink three or four of them and
still don't have a headache the next day
kind compliments on the grapes for the
wine grow on these slopes the Adam
Miller vineyard in Lyman is a 20-minute
drive from Heidelberg wine grower
Matthias Miller offers mulled wine not
only in a classic red variety but in
white and even rose a gun started to
nellies to Cleveland traditionally
mulled wine is made of red wine which is
how we make it let's but in recent years
there's been rising demand for white
wine because white wine has less tannin
it's lighter fruitier Stoffel hug which
is why people want a white mulled wine
when in forged and in heidelberg we have
a third variant a rose a mulled wine
come via a new devaglia it was made and
for pink monday unless a charity event
for an AIDS organization benefits for
installed on two goons and a silver
but what is responsible for that special
Christmassy taste of mulled wine natalie
miller who works together with her
husband reveals a family secret this led
zep not the invite and the recipe we
still used today is a very simple recipe
from our great-grandmother theater busty
partner in terms of the ingredients we
use just three spices cloves star anise
and cinnamon one and the fruits are
classic lemon and orange sit Warner and
Harsha the ancient Romans used to spice
and sweeten their wine when it was too
sour in the Middle Ages people believed
in the healing properties of the fruity
drink in Germany mulled wine first
became commercially available in large
quantities in the 1950s back in
Heidelberg the mulled wine goes well
with the hearty winter specialties like
potato pancakes and mushrooms
[Music]
there are a surprising number of mulled
wine stands here local people say wine
is simply a traditional part of the
Heidelberg lifestyle
sugar dried fruit and lots of spices are
the ingredients that go into making
mulled wine a tree two-faced and your
mother really only stands still making
the mold one ourselves after 31 years is
it's a lot of work it's crazy but we
love it and it's great quality for a
regular customers put knob and mulled
wine is good business to the stands
turned quite a profit here I feel warm
thank you guys I first mulled wine of
the year and the fragrance goes through
my nose into my entire body and gives me
such a feeling of home food anger comes
then Cimorelli a typical smell of a
christmas market is not the gingerbread
it's the mulled wine and with that the
city of heidelberg is well equipped for
the cold winter season
[Music]
you